Also man kennt seine Gäste alle.
Hildegard Schweinsberg
kennt alle und jeden,
denn sie ist seit mehr als 70 Jahren
hinter diesem Tresen zugange.
Jeden Tag mindestens 50 Bier gezapft.
Macht 15.000 pro Jahr,
in 70 Jahren locker eine Million Bier.
Am Zapfhahn macht ihr keiner was vor.
Das kann man nicht erklären.
Das kann man, das kann man lernen.
Man muss die Gläser beim Einschenken
schräg halten.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab‘ das so drin.
Und ich lass‘ auch ungern jemanden dran.
Hildegard Schweinsberg, genannt Oma Börse,
ist in diesem Haus geboren.
Angefangen hier zu arbeiten hat sie,
da war sie noch ein junges Mädchen.
Drei Kinder großgezogen, zwei Ehemänner
überlebt. Früher ging´s hier rund.
Und mit allen Gästen, dass es keine
Schlägerei gibt und so weiter, ja?
Das ist auch so ‘ne Sache. Bis jetzt ist
alles immer gut gegangen.
Die haben auch ein bisschen Respekt,
trotzdem ich schon so alt bin.
Fast jeder ist Stammgast in der Börse.
Alle kennen sich seit Jahrzehnten.
Wann war Herr Zahnow das erste Mal hier?
1961!
Das war vor 57 Jahren.
Herr und Frau Dörrbaum
kommen immer donnerstags,
für Bockwurst, Café und frisch
gezapftes Alster.
Aber natürlich kommen sie auch
wegen Oma Börse.
Viele, die früher in der Börse ein- und
ausgingen, sind inzwischen gestorben.
Oma Börse aber ist immer noch da.
Egal wie charmant sie eingeladen wird,
sie trinkt nie mit.
Seit 30 Jahren schon nicht mehr.
Kopfrechnen und Kopfschmerzen
vertragen sich nicht, sagt sie.
22,80 Euro. 22,80 Euro.
Reich wurde und wird sie hier nicht.
Aber die Einnahmen decken die Kosten
und irgendwie geht es ja auch um mehr
in der Börse: um die Gemeinschaft.
Dass die Börse mal schließt,
will sich keiner vorstellen.
Mit 87 Jahren immer noch täglich
100 Gläser spülen, trocknen, kontrollieren.
Bier bestellen, Abrechnungen machen.
Immerhin hat Oma Börse
inzwischen eine Halbtagshilfe angestellt.
Sonst tat die linke Schulter immer
weh vom Fallen.
Und jetzt tut die rechte Schulter auch weh,
aber das ist wohl von dem Wirtschaften.
Zwei Mal ist sie hingefallen.
Beim letzten Mal war sie sogar
im Krankenhaus und bat den Arzt,
sie schnell wieder fit zu machen:
Denn ihr Gasthof wartet.
Die Frage steht für alle Gäste im Raum:
Braucht Oma Börse nicht mal Ruhe?
Das liegt mir nicht.
Und ich brauch‘ die Menschen.
Und wenn ich meine Tür abschließe,
und der eine klopft und der andere klopft
– das kann ich gar nicht mit ansehen.
Drei Kinder, sieben Enkel und
fünf Urenkel hat sie,
aber keiner möchte die Börse übernehmen.
Also den Gasthof verkaufen?
Die Leute hier haben mir gesagt, weißte
was?! Da kriegst du höchstens 80.000!
Im Lotto sind 90 Millionen.
Und wenn ich die gewinne,
dann kauf‘ ich dir alles ab.
Ende! Oma Börse kauf ich mit!
Wollen wir mal Lotto spielen?
Ja, wollen wir mal…
Pogi, noch ein Bier?
Ja.
Sie gehört dazu. So eine Runde muss
man auch ein bisschen beherrschen?!
Muss man alles im Griff haben. Ja, die
sind auch manchmal ganz schön frech,
aber die kriegen auch Kontra
von mir zurück.
Nein, wenn das zu bunt wird, dann hauen
wir auch mal ein paar Bolzen raus.
Und das wissen sie denn ganz genau,
und da sagen sie auch:
Also, bei Oma Börse kann nicht jeder tun,
was er will. So.
Und wer wie Herr Zahnow einen über
den Durst getrunken hat,
dem organisiert Oma Börse die Heimfahrt.
Was wäre Neuhaus ohne die Börse?
Wer herkommt, geht beschwingt.
Mit oder ohne Alkohol.
So schön kann das Leben sein!
Tschüss!